vous savez je peux vous dire tout de
suite qu'il y en a qui pense que je suis
une fille des rues mais pas l'importance
d'autres pas parce que je suis au café
parmi un tas de frères qui sont ici et
chez nous rarement une fille rentrerait
au café
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont 500 000 en France 120000 autour
de Paris le nouvel étalgérien ne peut
pas encore les faire vivre l'industrie
reste embryonnaire et les naissances
dépasseront pendant des années les
emplois créés
pour tous ces Algériens venir en France
est une nécessité vitale mais tous
n'attendent pas la même chose de la
France pour les jeunes nés dans les
bidonvilles le drame c'est d'abord de
savoir qui on est
les bidonvilles c'est le ghetto la
France c'est l'Occident et pour
longtemps encore l'Algérie c'est un rêve
quel métier family
c'est-à-dire puzzer
on reçoit de la marchandise on l'apaise
et puis on voit combien qu'il y en a
pour rendre compte
faut pas trop si vous voulez c'est un
métier qui n'est pas très qualifié
75000 par mois
et vous tourner
bien sûr du moment que j'ai fait un
stage de 6 mois c'est justement pour le
pratiquer
et dans l'espérance de rentrer chez moi
un jour en Algérie en fin de santé des
si vous voulez est-ce que vous n'avez
pas un peu l'impression que les
espagnols les portugais les Algériens
sont là pour faire des travaux justement
difficiles dur pénible un peu dangereux
vous savez ils sont obligés de gagner
leur vie alors il faut bien qu'il
cherche un travail même
très très dangereux il faut qu'il
travaille pour gagner
leur vie élevée leur enfant
mais est-ce que ça vous paraît pas un
peu injuste ça
ben c'est des fois c'est je mets comme
je vous l'ai dit ils sont obligés de
faire de faire ça
et vous vous travaillez dans une banque
je crois oui j'ai travaillé dans une
banque maintenant c'est c'est l'arrêt
finale
parce que
je ne suis pas disons de nationalité
française et pour moi je ne peux pas
prendre cette nationalité là c'est
impossible pour moi car mon père est un
martyr de la Révolution algérienne pour
dire au juste
je me suis abstenu et puis j'ai quitté
cette banque là
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait maintenant
pas maintenant je vais chercher un
travail
différent si je peux trouver dans dans
un bureau si possible puisque mon métier
est un métier de bureau mais si je ne
peux pas trouver autrement j'irai dans
une usine faire le manœuvre pour
commencer il y a le racisme le français
dont on dit qu'il n'est pas raciste le
devient souvent face à l'Algérie se
dispute avec un Français l'autorité
française directement elle dit le fautif
là-dedans c'est l'Algérien et ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois de me disputer
avec des Français et puis celui qui
était embarqué pour aller au poste
c'était moi c'était pas un français mais
dans le métro ça vous est arrivé je
trouvais à côté de quelqu'un justement
qui est une réaction raciste
par exemple j'ai c'est rare que ça
m'arrive que des quand je suis assis
dans un siège que des Françaises des
jeunes françaises viennent s'asseoir
près de moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est un destin qui nous est fixé de
vivre dans cette boue en ce moment
pourquoi un destin comment ça puisque
les autorités françaises ne veulent pas
nous aider comment voulez-vous qu'on y
fasse quelque chose
alors on vit dans on marche et puis on
se dit ce soir on s'y rare nos
chaussures
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez là mes pieds ils sont tout
enfoncés et je peux rien faire
de un camarade par exemple et de le
faire rentrer dans mon baraquement ça me
gêne beaucoup beaucoup même je même
souvent beaucoup de camarades ne savent
pas que j'habite dans un bidonville je
leur dis même pas je leur dis j'habite
dans un pavillon luxueux vous savez
c'est pour me montrer pour pour dire que
je suis aussi bien placé que vous et
puis j'ai jamais invité à camarade
est-ce que ça vous est arrivé d'avoir
envie de connaître une fille
et qu'elle refuse de me connaître après
avoir su que vous étiez algérien oui ça
m'est arrivé oui
ça m'est arrivé parce que j'ai connu une
certaine fille et je ne lui ai jamais
dit que j'étais algérien bien le jour
que j'y ai dit que j'étais algérien m'a
dit monsieur vous m'excuserez mais
je ne savais vraiment pas que vous étiez
algérien et mes parents ne voudront pas
que je marche avec vous et j'ai connu
aussi une autre fille ses parents quand
je suis rentré chez eux ils m'ont dit à
algérien et algérien ça directement le
premier mot qui me l'ont dit
directement j'ai fait la réplique il y a
français français
c'est là que ça s'en est terminé mais
j'ai pas continué longtemps avec cette
fille là
parce que elle avait quand même un peu
le racisme qui l'habitait mais en France
on dit quelquefois lorsqu'on voit une
fille avec un Algérien ah bah ça c'est
une fille algérienne
alors vous lorsque vous sortez avec une
fille et que cette fille accepte de
sortir avec vous tout en sachant que
vous êtes algérien est-ce que il ne vous
ai pas arrivé d'avoir un peu de mépris
pour cette fille on a considérant comme
une fille algérienne
pour quelques-unes oui ça m'est arrivé
ça m'est arrivé parce que dans mon idée
je me disais cette fille là si elle
était vraiment une fille de classe et
c'était une fille correcte et très bien
je crois pas qu'il marcherait avec moi
ça m'est arrivé de dire ça rapide
Fatima est une amie d'Amar nous l'avons
rencontré dans un café mort Fatima est
presque parisienne elle a trouvé
facilement du travail mais elle est
femme et c'est elle la plus déchirée
qu'est-ce que pense les gens qui sont
autour de vous les frères ils sont au
café puis vous savez je peux vous dire
tout de suite qu'il y en a qui pensent
que je suis une fée des rues mais pas
l'importance d'autres pas parce que je
suis au café parmi un tas de frères qui
sont ici et chez nous rarement une fille
rentrerait au café
d'autres que pensent au contraire
diraient voilà une sœur qui est
civilisée à la bonne heure nous
commençons mettre un pas en avant
vous savez moi je ne vois pas que aucun
mal qu'une fille algérienne comme moi
rentrerait dans un café typiquement
algérien
bien ça quand il me voyais au bras de
français ça c'est autre chose vous savez
ça leur plaît pas beaucoup vous avez
adopté tout à fait le mode de vie
parisien oui j'ai adapté le mode de vie
parisien parce que voyez-vous depuis 17
ans que je suis ici je suis venu très
très jeune je me suis tout de suite
vu
élevé en France de la même manière que
mes petites camarades françaises je n'ai
pas très connu la vie d'aband en Algérie
je ne sais pas exactement quel est le
but d'une algérienne comment qu'elle
fréquente un homme là-bas mais je me
fais une opinion maintenant quand voilà
je les femmes elles me reproche beaucoup
de surtout dans la famille pourquoi que
je me voilerai pas et pourquoi une
grande fille comme moi comme ça
sortirait peut-être nue
oui ça me touche un petit peu de force à
force de l'entendre tous les jours ça me
touche
je pense que ça viendra pas tout de
suite mais en fait j'aurais pas
m'arrêter tout de suite mais si je
deviens me marier je pense que je me
marierai avec un gars de avec un frère
de tout à fait de chez moi en Algérie
quoi pourquoi
je peux pas vous répondre à cette
question parce que
premièrement point de vue pour mes
parents
[Musique]
m'intérieraient pas de Marie avec celui
que j'aurais fréquenté que j'aurais aimé
et tout ça enfin si je me marie avec
n'importe quel autre race mon père
trouverait à redire
mais vous
dans moi je suis obligé de l'accepter
dans notre religion la femme on dit que
c'est un jouet pour la
je vais pour vous
c'est la compagne disons d'un homme et
qui ne doit pas rentrer dans beaucoup de
choses personnelles qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire par là parce qu'il y a des
choses qui doivent être à une femme qui
a les intéresse mais il y a des choses
qui ne doivent pas vraiment aider à la
femme car je sais pas moi se prendra une
importance totalement au dessus de
l'homme
si vous vous mariez un jour
que ferez-vous de votre femme ma femme
qu'est-ce que j'en ferais elle sera
libre comme toute autre femme mais une
certaine liberté cette femme libre je
pense à Fatima par exemple est-ce
qu'elle est plus attrayante ou moins
attrayante que la femme algérienne
voilée que vous connaissiez du mal dont
vous avez entendu parler
on est très attrayante Fatima est très
attrayant elle est plus attrayante pour
vous parce qu'elle est occidentale
[Musique]
il est pour l'émancipation féminine
quant au contradiction des jeunes c'est
l'éducation révolutionnaire qui doit les
résoudre on va se mettre là d'accord
droit d'apprendre un métier ah oui ah
oui ah oui si le premier chose le
prendra le métier pour vivre pour qu'il
puisse arriver à vivre dans toute sa vie
évidemment pour travailler et s'il n'a
pas amitié il travaille il peut pas
vivre est-ce qu'elle pourrait se marier
avec un français ou avec un anglais ça
j'ai le commente pas ça si il se marie
avec ceux qui les plaît mais je veux
qu'elle se marie avec un homme qui
qu'elle est bien c'est à dire qu'il le
rendent pas malheureuse qui sera
heureuse avec lui et qu'il l'aimait et
qui lui l'aimait qui s'aimait bien tous
les deux je m'en fous oui ça m'est égal
oui ça soit on algérien ce soir en
français ça soit en italien que ça soit
un chinois le moment qu'elle trouve un
homme qu'il concerne c'est le principal
pour moi
cet homme soit musulman le mari de ma
fille
je vous dis je ne peux pas les choisir à
ma fille c'est elle qui l'a choisi le
marchand vers la civilisation et dans le
temps si les colonialisme qui nous ont
fait faire ces choses-là mais maintenant
ne reconnaissons que la civilisation la
première civilisation ça nous parvient à
nous donc nous pouvons jamais dire à
quelqu'un qui peut nous civilisé il
rejette des jeunes gens on a
l'impression qu'ils sont un peu plus
découragés un peu moins actif parce
qu'ils nous veulent moins à l'Algérie
que vous ne le pensez parce qu'ils
veulent pas vous donner leur
c'est-à-dire fond
qu'est-ce qui pense pour ce qui doit
vous dire parce qu'ils ont toujours une
une chose qui les empêche au prix de
vous parce que vous vous êtes français
ils veulent pas vous dire les choses qui
pensent
[Musique]